i feel like we have more chance of making
a difference talking to the ordinary people
who are actually being hurt and being affected
because they're going to see it and they're going
to be like this is affecting me and my family we
need to do something about it whereas i can talk
about it here with all these guys doing all
their maths & algebra, they don't care really
they're comfortable and their families comfortable
and their community is comfortable you know
this is Lamb & Flag, one of Oxford's many fine pubs
its my favourite pub, cash only for no obvious reason
this one's closed too
let's check one more time
for 'stand by me' man
if he's not there like... I just
hope that he's there basically
he's not here man,
'stand by me' man is not here
okay *are you alright?*
no it'sfine hopefully he's just... yeah
it's some really old church isn't it
yeah, no, yeah it's the Saxon tower
of Saint Michael at the north gate
the oldest church tower in Oxford
so this I think is Baylor college
which is um Boris Johnson's college
these are quite good... heads
that's where we did our matriculation
do you know what matriculation is?
it's like where you're likeformally
enrolled into the university
actually makes me you know what
like walking down these alleyways
makes me quiet suddenly really nostalgic
whatit was i thought there was maybe
I thought speakeasy, yeah I've never
that's the alternativename for
speak easy - stealth pub
this is it you can see how I [ ____ ] missed it
yeah turf is not far from econ department so um
yeah every now and again when i just got too too
pissed off at the nonsense that we were doing in
econ lectures I would just just leave and come
here and have a pint sometimes you've got to do it
so when I came here, 2017,  so I was30 years
old, about to turn 31, so I'd alreadyhad the
successful career in the city so like, itwas a
funny one for me because I did economics
and then i had a very successful career and I kind
of learned in my career that what I studied at
university was not particularly useful so i
kind of already thought like i'm coming here
you know I was one of the best paid economists
in the world you know what I mean so like
I'm thinking I'm coming here to discuss but
the professors... there were professors who
did exactly, looked at exactly the kind of stuff
that I did right: interest rates, central banks,
monetary policy... and I was like okay well you
know I'm one of the best paid people in the world
in this area, one of the most successful predictors
in the world in this area, let's talk about it...
and they were not interested um
*I know that's whatyou did*
*but I just mean* from a class perspective? by 30
31 I'd already been you know 6 years in the city
3 years at LSE and these are already places
where there is basically almost no people
from working-class backgrounds,actually
LSE wasn't as bad asthe City & Oxford
um so I've kind of becomeused to
this like you know you exist in the city
you're used to the fact that there's no people
from working class background um is it i mean
it's frustrating because when you're talking
about economics you're talking about issues
that affect people from working class
backgrounds andpeople from privileged
backgrounds differently, um it was frustrating
because someof my like people on my course
were just disconnected from what was
happeningand it's so easy for them to just
arguemathsand like little technical points
of philosophy but they don't really
you know like for me it affects my sister
you knowI mean? you know what I'm saying?
you know? and like my best friends from
childhood, but forthem it's like just like a
it's like a nicelike philosophical debate to have
in the pub orto have in the common room
you know i mean? and it isfrustrating
when like, you don't feel thatthey feed it on
an emotional level it's just like uh...
something to talk about... they don't
i think it's...you know... I think you know
lack of class diversityin a lot of areas
is important but in economics itjust has
this extra pain that you know we should
economists should be discussing the
economic problems of people's lives
*but it seems like the more advanced you've
got in economics the more exclusive it gets*
yeah definitely it does yeah for sure
*even withyou probably acclimatizing*
yeah like Post-grad was worse than Under-grad
and I'm sure if you do PhD it'd be worse
and then the professors are the worst of allyou know
what I mean um *would you consider doing aPhD?*
you know never say never but like when you
consider it would take so long and I feel like
when I worked in the city if you are very good at
what you do you can progress very quickly but I
feel like in academic economics it's a lot who you
know and just like do you play the game right and
you know listen listen i'm a nobody right like i'm
a short guy from a poor background in Ilford
I'm not like handsome like a model I don't
have no connections you know what I mean
I'm notexcellent football the only thing I've got is
I can make good predictions and like because
I understand the economy better than anyone else
that is enough to get to the top in the citybut
it gets you nowhere in academia, nowhere
so like i would have to spend years working the
game and making connections and doing all of this
stupid academic maths on whiteboards at the same
time the world's getting worse and worse and worse
and at the end of it there's no guarantee that I'm
going to fix anything and there are good people
in economics right there's most famously
ThomasPiketty but there's also Gabriel Zucman
Mian & Sufi, Ludwig Straub these guys right like
who are doing this stuff in the academic space but
i don't think it's really possible at the moment
even if you're saying exactly the right things
to actually push through in economics because
nobody nobody knows nobody cares whether you're
right or not nobody even notices whether you're
right or not you know what i mean so i feel
like we have more chance of making a difference
talking to the ordinary people who are actually
being hurt and being affected because they're
going to see it and they're going to be like
this is affecting me and my family we need
to do something about it whereas i can talk
about it here with all these guys doing all
their maths and algebra they don't care really
they're comfortable and their families comfortable
and their community is comfortable you know
so um never say never and I did enjoy like
you know I'm good at maths and algebra and
I enjoy doing it and I enjoy the beauty
of the model but the problem is the people
are too often I don't wanna act like everyone
ineconomics is a [ __ ] because they're not
there's a lot of good people but there
are a lot of people that are just just
chatting [ __ ] all the time basically and they
don't care they don't want to change anything
they're just careerists they just want to write
a load of papers and make a load of money
they don't care about being right they don't
care about what's happening it's frustrating
*it's sounds frustrating*
it's frustrating being there man
it was frustrating being there but
oh it's all right you know i went
gym every day what can you do
did a lot of algebra i made some goodmates
there are some good people here in the subject
*you know the economists you mentioned,
Piketty, what background are they from?*
i don't know actually to behonest
i don't know to be honest, um
Atif Mian is the one that I talk to
Ithink is it Atif Mian? yeah
*have they encountered similar difficulties?*
so he'sfrom Pakistan so obviously there's a lot
of poverty in Pakistan I don't know whathis
background is like, if he got into theindustry
he's probably not like from povertyor anything
um Ludwig Straub is German, Piketty
I don't know what these guys personal back..
I don't think they're from poor backgrounds
I don't know who's from a poor background
i dunno, there's another guy Ha-Joon Chang
that I like, he looks at kind of different stuff and
he's got he's well known he's got a lot of books
if anybody's like looking for more reading to
do like especially if you're interested in like
poorer countries you know there's a lot of
people who have family from poor countries
who might be watching and interested in the
situations in these countries he talks about that
um i don't know but like i mean when you meet
someone you don't automatically know their
background but you kind of you can get a vibe
from the accent and stuff what was amazing is like
this is Oxford, its the top university in England
there were no English accent you know what i mean
there was one guy on the course from Harrogate
which is in Yorkshire, had a Yorkshire accent
I don't think he was like strapped for cash
nice guy um there were like there was one
British-Indian guy from Manchester, no from
Birmingham, tried to pretend he's from Manchester
maybe from somewhere between, Stoke, yeah there
was no accents man and that's because everyone
is just from that same sort of rich background
from all different countries yeah it's a shame
I'm getting really emotional
I just haven't
i don't know there's something about
these alleyways that i like and
because i used to go to
this pub and have a couple
of drinks and then you sort of
stagger through these alleyways
it's a beautiful night as well like
after a rainy day suddenly we've got this
perfectly clear starry sky
poorer families will be forcedto lose almost
all of their assets... including their home
we have a tax system which isvery efficient
at taxing ordinary working people
but very inefficient at taxing the super rich